Did you check out that article saying a British person...
...took photos of a UFO hovering over southwest England?
Every time I see those articles or pictures about people witnessing UFOs,...
...I think that they are just so eager to see one,...
...but what they really see is not the same as what they want to see.
What about you? Do you believe in UFOs or aliens?
I remember after watching "E.T." when I was young,...
...I always dreamed about playing with an alien,...
...or taking a ride on a flying saucer.
If an alien does look like the one from "E.T.",...
...then I see no problem being a good friend with him,...
...but if it turns out to be a threatening, scary one,...
...then I would just run away from him.
Well, in fact,...
...there are many movies or books on UFOs or space attacks these days,...
...so I don't think it will be a big surprise if I see one,...
...unless it starts attacking people.
There is a comedy movie called "Scary Movie 3"...
...where there are a bunch of aliens...
...who came to the earth to goof around and then left.
I laughed so hard!
Well, more and more entertainment sectors choose aliens or UFOs...
...as a main topic so it's become a somewhat friendly issue.
You're right.
I can also find a lot of movies or comics...
...in which one of the characters is an alien with a somewhat strange face.
It was kind of weird when I saw it for the first time.
But these days I really enjoy seeing them.
If they really exist in the world,...
...I really want to meet them someday!